[Music]
it's alternate reality Kanye news oh
what the fuss made by Lenny from Chicago
Jaden Smith will play a young Kanye West
in a new Showtime series you shouldn't
play Kanye yet guess be way older for
you to play it like a biopic of him
that's what you think he funded it
himself probably it's a show about Kanye
yes that's a movie but Jaden is gonna
play young Kanye right they're not play
yeah so this is what happening limited
half-hour anthology series from Kanye
West don't use big words like that
what's anthology it's like a series of
like how many fires of stories or
whatever you know omniverse and it's
pretty much what Kanye West would be
like in different universes you have
like an alternate reality loka's level
of narcissism his narcissism is so good
we're all gonna watch master this is
Kanye at Avatar State this is Kanye in a
muppet state he just puts himself in all
different IPS honey a white person
connect skin I don't know if we can hang
as a Mexican who knows it's Kanye just
do you know like a song with pitbull
it's true like daddy yankee
daddy Yankees not Mexican no now there's
pitbull that's alright who's like a
famous Mexican rapper no are not there
no no no no there's a lot of Mexican pop
I'm just not up on it but there's this
huge mr. Caponi he's like oh sure he's
like ah sure yeah of Mexico Ricky Martin
he's not know if he's Martin's I'm
Mexican
no what is this a Puerto Rican
he's gay he's Mexican to me like all
that team a is from where Oh Eva Mendes
I don't know if she's Mexican Oh
Christina Aguilera she's Mexican
oh yeah he's half right or Colombian she
claims Mexican she's Mexican Christina
Aguilera's Mexican she like claims like
Shakira is Colombian she's half Colombia
we need more Mexicans out there oh my
god I just thought like I said no means
la has a lot of Mexicans there's not a
single Mexican rapper in LA who's doing
well that's dick mr. Carson tattoo
artist the next time you guys have to
get a Mexican rapper on the show no no
no Rob that's different yeah locals guys
know that's power 106 [ __ ] that you're
saying but they're Mexican rappers about
that one cholo that's a cholo in every
single movie that's gonna bring up when
when we went to go see endgame we saw
the trailer for the cheesiest movie ever
yeah who's the comedian you just George
Lopez yeah you've been it yeah no I know
like George Lopez the Kings awesome the
door breaker and then every Mexican
cholo it's ever been in any movie that
is Mike Rotolo keep they're all in this
one but awesome
even the [ __ ] push they want to support
it but it looks so bad my tickets and
don't go I wish they did it for your
people it's called a Chicano there would
be four people and Chicano
it looks so cheap really so bad is it
called crazy poor Mexican no she just
said what's the Asian version I was like
oh
Razia rich Asians they weren't about
Mexicans all crazy poor Mexicans like it
crazy rich Mexicans do I can't excuse my
hater your size mexicana keep it
accurate your wife is Mexican why do you
keep talking [ __ ] thank you but actually
he can he married
I'm taking this card back is the Mexican
part of seaweed seaweed the Chilean lime
snacks gotta go real it's the [ __ ]
line you suck at being a Mexican dear
Chilean sacred Mexican card away right
now take the white this all tie okay
well do you behave like sweet days yeah
they're saying that Jaden Smith is gonna
play looked oh no not yet oh he is weird
and artsy enough to play alternate
reality you know I will say this I think
he'll do a good job
I think he will but like I don't know if
the show will be good but I think he'll
do written by Diaz no this is Ali song
Jen he did undone agents agents know
he's a Korean guy sounds Korean right
yeah I don't claim him he might be a
filmmaker from Korea you undone is no no
you I don't know there's so much may
have just fired I've just got fired from
12 different projects straight up the
last thing that Jada Smith it was the
get down get down Netflix show based on
the second musical kind of yeah yeah
yeah afro it was cool it was the one he
did with his dad to space one Karate Kid
no space 1 that was the worst movie I've
ever seen hands down that film was like
I feel like an hour and 20 minutes I
couldn't get through it I thought it
felt like four hours and I'm not very
very snobby like I enjoy sci-fi [ __ ] it
has to be pretty cool it was the worst
[ __ ] film I've ever seen so that the
writing acting was bad the writing was
bad the CG was bad like it just didn't
make sense what about the first one when
they were homeless and he had to sell
those machines
oh we're suit of happiness all pursuit
of half that [ __ ] I was like selling
Russia I was like are you talking about
German that [ __ ] should hold a series of
unfortunate events no no I can't watch
that one Pursuit of Happyness
catch
used to watch it cuz I knock see oh my
oh [ __ ] yeah it's just non-stop this guy
can't get a break that's I can't watch
dogs maybe the only animal movie I've
ever seen is homeward bound you can see
Beethoven
I can't watch dog movies either why cuz
I get you sad you didn't see that you'll
admit zombie one where he had his dog
did you watch that
oh yeah so happens to have a dog that's
not a dog lady
movie that you you know you're going
into where you know well you should
watch Beverly Hills Chihuahua then dogs
go to heaven
that's the animation animated movies I'm
not connected but like what is it
Marlene me I can't watch that movie
you're talking like those who I died a
dog's purpose yeah I can't watch feel
bored it's just the dog eyes that's it
like a trailer maybe ball I rather get
stabbed in the chest for Peter you sure
watch it you big a backup it'd be tough
similar right you feel that pain in your
chest is because of the sadness of it or
just sucks both oh oh well yeah I'm
gonna see a shitty movie and then be
just devastated at the end let me tell
you something right now there's a lot of
people to comments that I [ __ ] hate
you you heartless bastard
Oh second of all I agree because I I'm
emotionally attached to dogs me too
that's why I can't do it don't watch
Hachi which one Hachi
the Japanese story yeah so it's [ __ ]
up
they made a shrine appache it's as I can
oh yeah yeah
though this doggy is so loyal okay the
owner and the doggy used to go to the
train station all the time and in the
diamond Tisha's get some tissues ready a
life story and the doggy would always
wait I like him because when he comes
off the train yeah you'll come and pick
him up yeah and he died but in the doggy
always went every single day and waited
there one day
oh my god and then they did an American
version of a day why watch that damn
story was the American version because
that gold retriever
it was homeward bound three it was still
a Shiba but then it was with like not
Bruce Willis a white washy but yeah
there's a white story about a dog dog
Jake Starbucks the Omni
here so they're saying this is what the
only like thing that they're talking
about or like that they're mentioning
about this show so they're saying
omniverse is not set in our world nor
about our worlds Kanye West as we aim to
add a new spin on alternate realities
consciousness and push the limits of
half our narrative I can't wait to see
reptilian Jaden Smith that's Kanye so
he's gonna be like iguanas and it's not
about Kanye in our universe so like
maybe they'll be like a Kanye Kim K sex
tape in the show she'll like get back in
I would be awesome dude I just I should
be a writer there's a different universe
I'm redeeming myself yeah it's a
different universal they're like aliens
yeah yeah in one universe there are
motorcycles and then it's a love story
between a sport bike and a cruiser well
they're saying that season 1 is going to
explore the ego
oh there's multiple seasons oh [ __ ] so
there must be a big show then because
that [ __ ] ego is impenetrable
the first episode of the first season is
even that makes more sense even one
explores the ego through an alternate he
already has like 20 seasons written now
and in its 8 episodes of how he's the
best season 1 episode 49 but he's Kanye
West and he does dope [ __ ] sometimes
what he said you don't remember the
story of the day no no I mean his first
couple of albums are incredibly I'm
credible just talking about his [ __ ]
clothes recently the shoes oh [ __ ]
deal with that [ __ ] dude hey you gotta
have confidence to rock you're not
dealing with it but guess what he
doesn't give a [ __ ] because he's balling
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] either
nonporous oh no no he's doing something
right yep let's all get on the show
we should be nah we should all play
Kanye you know I would love to be the
Korean Kanye yeah how do we do that
you're you should know better than us
I'll call you I'll of diem Jada my name
is Kanye West and I do dope [ __ ] yeah
that's what I love it have you ever seen
black nurse one episode only one gotta
watch all of those maggots some good
stuff why I have to hold I know after I
watched one I was like I'm who's [ __ ]
yeah mmm so good I'm gonna watch Russian
doll you gotta watch Russian doll you
got to watch all my shows first I'll
watch and all so like I said stitchers
that should be somewhere Hulu or
freeform and
I'm the voice of Ken Barbie and Ken
we're on Netflix
it's called Barbie's Dreamhouse
infection you're gonna make this watch
Bob RV adventures mm-hmm everyone we're
gonna do watch would be dream house
adventures on Netflix I'm not gonna be
happy that's not gonna do brown guy
doing the voice of a [ __ ] white dude
yeah you can bro I've known so many
crushes chicken tikka masala every day
episode just slip in a slight little
Indian accent every time it's pretty
much just me but okay let's go hey
Barbie how you doing today you want to
come over and we'll play some basketball
I believe it if you could play with this
[ __ ] can play with this [ __ ] god I
hope you can play with this [ __ ] kid
Barbie you only has pelvis it's actually
it's actually really cute it's good for
kids good for girls you said you only
had pelvis
yeah Barbie Lynch oh there's no [ __ ]
excuse me what do you take the clothes
off the doll I try to bend her over she
got a flat ass okay with my friend
sister's Barbies
[Music]